a new poll the story really really spoke
to me
so a new poll say that 53 of couples say
there is just one issue that's as
important as sex yeah i was thinking
what could it be i was thinking money
yeah that would be an obvious one but
that is like famous for
being a huge issue in relationship yeah
well metro reports that the answer is
household chores
the poll found 40 of couples have gotten
into more fights about who does the
chores or more or less since the
pandemic started i believe that 50 say
they're not doing their share of the
cleaning and it says well they say it's
as bad as cheating i don't agree with
that that's nuts that okay yeah it is
not as bad as cheating i would much
rather prefer you don't fold your
laundry then you like rip clothes off a
stranger you know what i'm saying a
hundred percent yeah but it surprised me
that people are fighting this much about
cleanliness but i guess it's because
we've all been stuck in the house
together
for so long like it's right welly my
fiance does this thing where he'll use a
paper towel and just sort of leave it
there oh like harry and sex in the city
with the tea bags exactly and it's you
know it's sort of cute like oh hi you
left this
but
i bet after like a year and a half of
just us in a box it would be like
if you leave one more
paper towel on the table i mean does
this get to you and are you the messy
one
you know um i
it's me and my two girls so you know
some days we're better and some days
we're not you know some days like the
dishes go past the
spigot you know up high in the sink and
some days like we're all loading the
dishwasher together i mean
so i like that me and my current
roommates yeah you know we can get on
each other's cases or we can back off so
we're not a couple i don't live in that
type of situation so for everybody who's
stuck in the same house together you
made that choice honor that choice by
figuring out your boundaries and
expectations and trying to meet them and
not driving each other crazy because
you're only doing it to yourself exactly
and each other and just shift your focus
and love them did i see somebody who
just looked at each other did you just
look at him i thought you go
uh oh
may i ask um if you don't mind
contributing to this conversation what's
your name my name is angela angela do
you currently reside with the gentleman
next to you my husband yes and what is
his name his name is pedro and why did
you look at him
well
um he's very helpful around the house
but sometimes i do have to remind him to
do the obvious things you know take out
the trash and when i asked he does it
though he's really good but
you know it should be obvious you know
when
when the trash is piling over or the
dishes are up here you know but i have
to give them a little nudge every so
often
is there anything you have to nudge
angela about
no comment
a good understood smart man
all right next up um we love to try out
the latest gadgets in gear and today
we've got something new to test out in
drew's reviews
okay i am so excited about this i can't
oh god we're rolling carrots here okay
today's pick comes from viewer katie lee
thank you katie it's the bamboo land
cutting board and this thing is going
viral on tick tock people are calling it
a meal prep miracle and you can slice
and dice and catch your veggies and
these little removable drawers
do you want to demonstrate raw more than
anything i've ever wanted to do in my
entire life do you know i love chopping
in the kitchen it's cathartic for me
look at this so i'm gonna grate some
cheese right here this is right on top
and i'm
look and then pull the drawer out hello
how about this
be careful on this mandolin
okay this love it
i
i'm just like
where have you been my whole life yeah
because it's not that complicated right
when you think about it like oh a
cutting board with a little cubby yeah
but why did it take us
two billion years to figure this out
right
um okay i just want to say that i want
to give this you know it's usually five
out of five stars
i'm going to give this like infinity
times infinity stars
understood
i
okay how's that
that's a great how's that rating okay
but ready for my rating it's it's almost
a perfect five star right but it's a
four point eight star and i'll tell you
what tell me why rossi because look when
i go like this to put the the rest in
look there's a little divot here
right here i can't get
i can't get it past see so if you did
this and just made it smooth that'd be a
five star and that's just a suggestion
from uncle ross
[Music]
you